um back with BuzzFeed
and there's no puppies
hey what's up guys I'm Tom Holland and
today I'm here with BuzzFeed and I'm
going to be answering 30 questions as
quickly as possible
and eggs benedict this morning two
lattes with double shots and an orange
juice so I am so wired right now
my best friend Harrison he's living in
my house right now and the gate is
broken so the only way for he can get
out the house is if I remotely open the
gate from my phone so that is that is
what we're dealing with right now
oh I actually finished last night
watching my first season of Survivor I
loved it I'm so deep into the
backstabbing and what do they call it in
Survivor the thing they do when they
like all go against one person
blindsiding people I love it I can't
wait to start it again
Sunny by Bob herb HEB HEB Bob Hebb Bobby
head
Meryl Streep I'd love to work with her
Killian Murphy again and Leonardo
DiCaprio
secretive inspiring and educational
people that talk about themselves too
much we call them me monsters or an 11 a
reef because in the UK Tenerife is a
really good place to go on holiday if
you've been to 11 a reef which is an
imaginary place it means that you're
always one better than Tenerife so if
someone is continually talking about
themselves at dinner and they're
one-upping you all the time and it's
exhausting me and my friends will always
say oh this guy's just got back from 11
Arie and they don't know what it means
but now they do
I have no reason whatsoever I have
limited rizz my brother Patty has
ultimate raise I don't know I need you
to fall in love with me really for it to
work so long game probably making a
movie with each other it definitely
helps when the characters you're playing
are falling in love with one another you
can sort of blur the lines a little bit
that's kind of where my wrist is at and
I'm you know I'm locked up so I'm happy
and in love so I've got no need for Riz
my onset bestie would be one of my real
life best friends which is Ben Perkins
he was my acting coach throughout this
experience and to be perfectly honest
with you I couldn't have done it without
him probably physical touch and words of
affirmation I like I like both of those
things those are important to me
Emma LED is definitely the most likely
to throw a party afterwards
probably Downey we'd have a good time
he'd figure out a good way to survive
he's invested a lot into machines that
can generate fresh water from thin air
and stuff like that he's doing all the
right things so if I if he could bring
one of those machines with him I think
would be pretty good
in an environment that was incredibly
dark and serious she always brought the
light to set so I really loved her
bubbly persona
obnoxious
less obnoxious
Zendaya it's Non-Stop and she sends me
too much it's like I can't keep up
because I delete my Instagram for days
at a time I download it to post and then
I have to check my messages and I'll
have hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of things from that and I try and keep
up but it's intense
the crowded room reviews
Zendaya easy
I think my Spider-Man movies in my
personal preference would be one three
two
I would probably have the Patek Philippe
olive green Nautilus olive green is my
favorite color so when they brought that
watch out I couldn't quite believe that
they had brought out not only my
favorite watch but in my favorite color
I did everything I could possibly do to
get that watch and um
I failed miserably
one of the Harry Potter movies
to be honest I'd love to be in Billy
Elliott again but maybe as Tony or even
as the dad like way down the line I
think that would be a lot of fun
the people you'd struggle to find a city
with greater people than New York
Lewis Hamilton I'd love to try and drive
one of those cars and like he's
obviously you know he's the best at it
and no one does it like him he's an
amazing bloke and someone that I really
admire
um so to step into his shoes albeit he
does wear crazy shoes would be an honor
my most useless Talent is
I can make a water droplet by flicking
my cheek
hold on
no
you said a useless talent because I
can't even do it
damn we'll come back to it
the wildest rumor that I've ever heard
about myself is recently that I decided
to become sober after having a meltdown
on set which is wildly untrue
um I decided to give up drinking long
before I stepped on to set the grounded
room
um I was really lucky I did so I think
had I been drinking during this show it
would have been a very different
experience so that's probably the
craziest one I've heard in a while
I really love carpentry I've been
building stuff at my house I've got
something that's arriving at the end of
this month that I'm really excited to
build which I'm going to do in my garden
I'm very lucky that some of my best
friends are all professional carpenters
and build film sets so I'll have a good
set of hands to kind of help me figure
it out but I think I would have made a
pretty good living out of being a
carpenter
I want to say something like forest
green because that's my favorite color
but I'm really pink or something bright
yellow bubbly I'd love to say forest
green because it seems quite cool and
brooding but that isn't who I am
definitely the cry face the smiley cry
face that's the one I use the most I
feel like it encapsulates so many
different emotions while being very
clear as to the way you're using it
we were lucky enough to go this year and
we really want to go back so I'm not
going to tell you that because I don't
want the paparazzi showing up when I'm
on a beach after having not been to the
gym for six months and not feeling great
about myself
I can't say that here
well look I have two there's that one
and then and then there's that one
and they're mine I'm Tom Holland and
I've been with BuzzFeed answering 30
questions my new Apple TV Plus show the
crowded room is out now